Hello, and welcome to the educational session on epistasis and
evolution, how genetic interactions shape cancer trajectories.
I'm really pleased to see everyone here today.
We have a good lineup of speakers to talk about the topic.
I just want to remind everyone about the way that this is scheduled.
We're going to each have 20 minutes to talk for the
speakers with five minutes for questions afterwards.
So please do ask your questions in the five minutes, but if you're thinking about a
complex question or a simple question, maybe the simple questions during the
five minutes afterward, because we're going to have a panel discussion at the end.
So if it's a broader, more theoretical, longer question, you may want to
reserve that for the panel discussion at the end of the session, okay?
Thanks very much again for your attention here.
I'm just going to move right along then
to our first speaker,
Jaime Aranzo,
who has done some excellent work on epistasis and evolution and will be
explaining some of that to you today.
Come on up, Jaime.
Welcome him, please.
All right. So good morning, and thank you for the
introduction and for putting together this session.
Today, I'm going to talk about genetic interactions in cancer, how to detect
them, how to model them, and why we should care.
As you probably know, cancer is an evolutionary process that happens
within our bodies and during our lifetime.
The process starts when a cell
acquires a mutation that provides it a fitness advantage
over the adjacent cells. So the cell is going to
proliferate, it's going to become locally abundant, and it's going to establish a
population of cells with a mutation.
Okay, the population can accumulate further mutations, and sometimes in the end,
that eventually may end up leading to cancer.
These mutations that promote cancer progression are called drivers,
and they tend to occur in specific genes that we call cancer genes.
An important
detail is that driver mutations are a minority.
So most of the mutations are neutral or even slightly
deleterious from the perspective of tumor progression.
We call those passengers.
So I probably don't need to convince you that
identifying and quantifying drivers is relevant.
They're going to give us information about the genetic basis for cancer,
and they can also help us identify potential therapeutical targets.
But it is a challenging task,
mostly because they are the minority.
So how can we infer driver mutations?
There are several approaches to that.
The one I'm going to present is, I like it especially because it
uses methods and ideas from evolutionary genetics.
So the idea is that we start from a very large collection of cancer sequencing data
for the cancer type of interest.
From that collection, we are going to extract synonymous mutations, and we are
going to use those mutations to
build a mathematical model, a null model of
mutations. So with that model, with that statistical model, we
can estimate the expected number of
mutations that we will see in a tumor in the absence of
selection. And that's why we're using synonymous mutations.
We assume that they are silent, and because of that, they are not subject to
selection.
Now, we can also estimate the number of non-synonymous mutations that we would
expect in the absence of selection.
And then what we do is to compare that number
with the observed number of non-synonymous substitutions or mutations in
general.
And then we calculate the difference,
and the difference is equal to the number of mutations that have reached detectable
frequencies in our sample because of selection.
And within our evolutionary framework,
mutations subject to positive selection are the driver mutations.
So we
can not only say if there are driver mutations in a gene or not, we can actually
quantify how many or how often we find them per sample.
This is implemented in a software called the NDSCV that was developed by Iñigo
Martín-Correa from Sanger Institute. So this is not our work.
But
also, you probably know driver mutations do not act alone.
Okay, so we have the drivers, but we know that often we need more than one
driver to induce cancer, and actually, very often, drivers work
together. This is a classical example, MYC and K-RAS.
So if both of them are together, they can promote tumors.
If we only have one, normally nothing happens.
And that's a classical example of genetic epistasis in cancer.
So the idea of epistasis is that the effect of
a mutation depends on what other mutations are present in a
cell.
We can formalize this mathematically. I'm going to show it more graphically.
So this will be the idea. Imagine that we have two genes, gene A and gene B, both
are cancer genes. And then we look at what's the tumorigenic potential
of mutations in gene A, this one here. Can you see there?
Yeah. So if there are only genes in this particular example, if there are mutations
in gene A, nothing happens. The tumorigenic potential doesn't increase.
But if we have mutations in A and B, then the cell becomes very tumorigenic.
So the effect of this mutation in A depends on whether we have mutations in B or
not.
We call this positive epistasis, and in terms of selection, what we
would find is that selection for mutations in A only happens if
there are also selections in B. We have conditional selection.
The same for negative epistasis. In this case, mutations in A are tumorigenic,
but if there are also mutations in B,
it doesn't work so well for the cell.
That's negative epistasis, and in terms of selection, we will see that
selection for drivers in gene A is conditional to having also
drivers in gene BAnd just as a note,
synthetic lethality will be an extreme case of this.
It's when we have double mutation, it's lethal for the tumor.
So now we have this
mathematical theory of how epistasis relates to conditional selection, we can
actually design an algorithm to quantify epistasis.
It is the following. We start again with a large data set of
cancer sequences. We are using The Cancer Genome Atlas.
And then what we're going to do is to stratify our data set in two groups.
One that has mutations in a given gene, we call it the split gene, will be B in the
previous example.
And then for each group, we are going to estimate selection,
using the strategy that I presented before, the NDSCV.
And we apply that to a query gene, the gene A in the previous example.
And then we compare the number of drivers
in both groups.
Okay? If that difference is positive, it means that there is positive epistasis
between mutations in genes A and B. There is synergy between those two genes.
And if the difference is negative, it means that there is negative epistasis, so
there is interference between those two genes.
We put together this algorithm in an R package called cosalliance that you
can find in GitHub. And there is also, we published a tutorial, and
if you want to use it and have difficulties, you can feel free to contact me.
So
let's put this into practice, and let's see what we can learn about epistasis in
cancer.
One of the things what we found is that positive and negative epistasis is quite
abundant. And actually, positive epistasis is more frequent than
negative epistasis. We see a lot of synergy.
Also, when we compare among different cancer types, we see that there is some
variability, but in general, between one-quarter and one-half of
driver mutations are affected by positive
epistasis. So this is important, qualitatively and
quantitatively.
But we can go a bit farther than that.
We can build epistasis networks. So I'm going to describe what it is.
Here, each circle will represent a cancer gene.
The size is proportional to how often that cancer gene has driver
mutations in a particular cancer type,
and the arrows show if there is positive, green, or negative, purple,
epistasis.
This may remind you of analysis of co-occurrence and mutual
exclusivity in cancer, and that's because it has something to do with
that. There is a difference. We are building these networks using
this idea of conditional selection, and that helps us control
for confounding variables like mutational load, difference in
mutational profiles, and we can also identify asymmetric relationships.
I will talk about that later.
Also, something that I want to point out in this figure, this is quite
representative, is that these networks typically are something that we call sign
modular. So you can identify modules like these three genes here,
or these four genes here, of genes that are synergistically with
each other,
and they are antagonistic with the genes from different modules.
And that has interesting implications.
So this is as a cartoon.
In a real example, this will be the network for low-grade glioma, and I
will show you these modules that I just described. Here, we have three genes.
They are all connected by positive interactions.
Then we have two genes here, will be a second module, third module
here, and then four and five are two isolated genes.
The idea of this modular structure is that,
once you have mutations in a given module, selection is going to promote
other mutations in the same module, and it's going to go against mutations in
different modules. So if you look at a particular tumor in a particular patient,
you will typically find mutations only in one of these modules of the network.
And because of that, we can classify a tumor based on which genes of the
epistasis network are being active or have mutated.
Once we have that, we can, for example, compare the survival.
This is the data for this particular tumor, and we see that different modules of
the epistasis network are associated with significantly different survival.
So this is helpful because it tells us that it's not just individual genes.
We can use sets of genes to make better predictions about patient survival.
First message to take home, mutational profiles associated with network
modules are informative of patient survival.
We can go a step further. We can look at other tumors, and we can identify
these modules and see what else can we learn.
So here,
I want to point out something that came out to-- we realized when we were
looking at these networks, is that the modules of the network typically have a
correspondence with genes that are associated with specific
molecular subtypes or well-characterized clinical subtypes of tumor.
For example, for endometrial cancer on the left, we have this module here.
If we look at the genes in that module, those are the genes that are typically
mutated in endometrioid type 1 endometrial cancers.
These other two genes are the typical markers of copy number high
subtype. And for colorectal cancer, we have the same.
This will be the module associated with a canonical pathway to colorectal cancer.
This other module is associated with
consensus molecular subtype 1.
So there seems to be this association, and now when we try to zoom out
and go into some more conceptual question, is if you think of tumors
in different patients and you think of them as evolutionary processes,
they are completely independent processes.
So a tumor in a person and a different person, those have happened
independently. Mutations have been accumulated independently.
Those are completely independent evolutionary
trajectories. However, the fact that we can
define clinical and molecular subtypes means that they actually
converge towards some specific phenotypes.So for an
evolutionary biologist like me,
that's quite interesting because that's an example of evolutionary
convergence. We see independent processes leading to the same
outcomes.
And the formal question here is: why does it happen?
What is driving this evolutionary convergence of cancer?
Now, our hypothesis is that the key is this modular
architecture of epistasis network. Okay?
We hypothesize that when you have a modular epistasis network,
evolutionary processes on those networks are going to be canalized towards specific
phenotypes, which would correspond, in the case of cancer, to consensus molecular
subtypes or clinical subtypes.
To test that hypothesis,
we did some mathematical models. So we started with
the empirical epistasis networks and also with toy ones.
We basically simulated the process by which cells accumulate mutations, then there
is selection, and in the end, what we have for each realization of the model is a
matrix
with the genes in the columns and the different replicates in our
in silico tumors in the rows, and then we know which genes are mutated in
which tumors. Then we can run a PCA and see if there are
classes of tumors, like different groups.
This is basically we are trying to
replicate this idea of
investigating possible subtypes from our in silico data.
And what we found is that for some structures of the network, we
can recover different well-determined
subtypes, and that happens when the network has these
kind of structures here. So it's basically signed modular.
This will be more or less what we see in real tumors.
So I think interesting here is that
actually in these networks, the first mutation determines which
module of the network is going to be mutated.
So if the first mutation falls here on the left module, for example,
the tumor is going to evolve to this subtype, to the left subtype.
If the first mutation falls here, just by chance, the tumor is going to
evolve to this right subtype,
which means that just by knowing very early
mutations, we can predict what subtype of tumor is going to
evolve, assuming that that lineage actually evolves into cancer.
So that will be the second take-home message, is that early
mutations in these pretumoral lesions can help predict
future tumor subtypes. And that's, again, because of this
particular structure of epistasis networks in cancer.
And then I will
go back to this idea of asymmetry in epistasis.
So as I mentioned before, because we use conditional selection to
infer epistasis, we can actually infer asymmetric relationships.
Some of them, like this here on the top, are symmetric, so APC and TP53
in colon cancer. In principle, both are synergistic with each other.
So it doesn't matter
if the mutation occurs first in APC or in TP53, the
synergistic effect is going to work more or less the same.
And then we have other cases, like these ones that I'm showing at the bottom,
where the epistasis is clearly asymmetric.
So, say, a mutation in TP53
critically increases the effect of mutations on this RB1 gene in
glioblastoma, but not vice versa.
If we have first the mutation in this RB1 gene,
then that doesn't really modify the
tumorigenic effect of TP53,
which is the same for many other genes.
This asymmetry is actually
establishing some sort of logical ordering for
mutations. So the idea is that if we have a mutation first in this first gene,
then mutations in these genes are going to have an effect.
If it's in the other
direction, doesn't really matter.
And because of that,
what we concluded is that asymmetry in the epistasis network is informative of
the order in which mutations happen.
So we tested that with genetic mutation data, which is this
figure on the right, and we saw that this idea is true.
So basically, the directionality of the epistasis network is informative
of the temporal sequence in which mutations occur.
It's basically telling us that there is a primary cancer gene and then a
secondary cancer gene.
That's about the directionality of the interactions.
We can also look at the position of a gene in the epistasis network.
So this is also a theoretical
work that we did a couple of years ago.
And here we study basically how does the position of
a gene in the network affect its tumorigenic potential.
In this particular case, we are studying a scenario in which the tumor
can also accumulate slightly deleterious mutations.
And because of that, basically, there is tug-of-war between driver mutations and
passenger mutations. You need to accumulate drivers fast enough to actually escape
this deleterious effect of passengers.
Otherwise, the tumor doesn't progress, which is a model that has been proposed to
explain why many healthy tissues or just
regular tissue have driver mutations and they never progress to cancer.
And what we found is that actually cancer happens when you have a mutation
in key genes of the epistasis network,
especially in genes that occupy central positions of the network.
So this is telling us that
the position that the gene occupies in the epistasis network is relevant, and
actually those that are hubs, that are here in central positions,
are acting as gatekeepers. It's not the same to get an early mutation in a
peripheral gene than in a central gene.
So again, by determining the structure of epistasis network, we can identify which
genes are these potential gatekeepers.
This is all based on simulations. We are now
working on verifying this with actual data from cancer models
in mouse.
So the third message would be that the structure of epistasis network reveals
central gatekeeper genes.And, well, I'm
a bit quick today, so with this, I'm getting to the
final conclusion. We'll have more time for discussion, so that's good.
The first idea that epistasis is pervasive in cancer evolution.
This epistasis network organizing modules,
which are groups of genes that act in synergy to promote cancer progression
and have widespread antagonism between genes of different
modules.
The epistasis networks are informative.
They are informative of different patient survival, so we can get better
predictions by looking at sets of genes instead of at individual genes.
By mapping early mutations to their corresponding network modules,
we can predict future properties for the tumor.
Particularly, we can predict which is the future subtype that will evolve from that
pretumoral population.
And finally, central genes in the epistasis network act as gatekeepers,
so determining the network can help us identify key genes.
Yes, I want to thank my team and my funding agencies, and
we'll be happy to take any questions.
Thank you. If you have questions, please walk up to the microphones.
Hi.
Is it working? Yeah. Thank you for the talk, very didactic.
I have a question about the software you're using.
Can you use it for epistasis between mutations and
epigenetic changes, like
areas of the genome that are open or not open, things-
Yes. So the method is based on stratifying your dataset in two groups.
You can use any criterion to stratify your dataset.
We use high mutations in a split gene or not, but you can use having
epigenetic modification or not,
being exposed to some risk factors or not.
The thing is that then you can do it bidirectionally.
So you will split based on that, and you study the effect of that variable, let's
say, epigenetic modifications on the genetic aspect
of the somatic mutations.
The way we implemented it, and actually the way we designed it, I
can't think of an obvious way to do it the opposite.
So to study how somatic mutation affects selection
on epigenetic modifications.
I will have to think about that. It's not trivial.
But the other way, from epigenetics to selection on somatic mutations, yes,
it's trivial.
Actually, the way the
tool is implemented, it's very easy.
Thank you for a great talk. Very cool. I'm Song Yang from Stanford.
So I have two questions. The first one is, this model can
consider the functional impact on protein for each of the mutations?
So the missense mutation can have a different impact on
protein, right? So-
Mm-hmm. So pardon, can
you repeat the first-
So if this model can consider the
functional impact on-
Ah
... gene structure or protein. So there are many missense
mutation which can have a different impact on-
Yes. So actually, something that I didn't mention is when we are stratifying the
dataset based on the presence or absence of mutations, we are taking into account
the effect. So basically, we are putting on one side
tumors that have
high effect mutations, and on the other group, tumors that have synonymous
mutations, no mutations, or low effect mutations.
So that can be taken into account when you stratify your dataset.
As for the effect, you don't really have to because
what you are quantifying is directly how many more mutations you see that you would
expect by chance. And that's giving you already a measurement of, if those
mutations you see them and you don't expect to see them, it's because they are
doing something.
Yeah. My next question is, how about this copy
number variation affecting many driver mutation at once?
Like a deletion in specific arm of chromosome can delete
tens of tumor suppressor gene at once.
So can this kind of be affected, this network?
Mm-hmm. Yeah, so that's a really good point.
I don't think we've looked at that.
However, there are some papers on that.
For example, I can think of Solid Park, who has looked at
genetic interactions between somatic mutations and copy number variation.
Of course, the effect in some cases, this is really fascinating, copy
number variations can modify the sign of epistasis between two
somatic mutations. So you can find some mutations that are synergistic or
antagonistic, and then if you have a copy number variation in a third gene, then
the sign of the interaction between these two genes changes.
So maybe we can take just one quick question from the right-hand side of the room,
and then please reserve your question for the panel discussion at the end.
Hi. Hi, I'm Kaylee in Dr. Alice Rodney's lab.
I maybe just missed it. In the inputs, is this
single-cell based data or bulk?
Bulk.
It's bulk sequencing data, yes.
Bulk sequencing?
Yeah.
How do you suspect potentially-
How what?
... a single cell could potentially influence that?
Just thinking if these alterations are actually happening in the same cell for
that gene network to be happening.
Well, one of the problems we have when we work with bulk data is
that we have to decide if a mutation is frequent enough to consider that
it's basically not rich fixation, but its frequency is higher
than you would expect just by chance,
or its frequency is just compatible with just neutral
diversification of a population.
So probably with single-cell data, we could address this in a more
systematic way. We could actually develop a theory to decide
if, for a given mutation at a given abundance,
its abundance is compatible with a just
random mutation background in the TC or actually subject to selection.
So I think it could actually be used to really improve the performance of the
method.But we haven't really
started working on it yet. But I think it's a logical next step now that single
cell data are becoming actually available.
Thanks for all these excellent questions.
All right. I would just like to introduce our next speaker,
Jorge Alfaro-Murillo,
at Universidad de Costa Rica.
And the title of Jorge's talk for you today is Quantifying
Epistasis and Evolutionary Trajectories in Cancer.
Thank you,
Jeff,
for the invitation. Thank you all for being here.
And
yes, I'm going to start just by mentioning
again about driver genes,
just because this is actually what we're looking for.
It's actually what drives cancer, right?
So,
Jaime already told you about driver genes.
This is the first publication about driver genes, where
they identify 719
cancer-driving genes, and the list has been
updated since its publication in
2018, but there hasn't been that many genes added.
So
as Jaime was saying,
one of the most important thing is that the most
genes or most mutations, we believe that they don't cause anything.
They're just either damaging for the cells, and we don't see them,
or they're just there for the ride, considered passengers.
But one of the
most important things I want you to get out of this talk is that
it's not an either/or. It's not that you have driver genes
or passenger genes, but it's also important to see how much of a
driver something is. So besides identifying one, you should
be able to compare them. You should be able to say, this one
is giving more advantage to the cancer
than this one, and by how much. And that's what we want to get out of
our framework. We want to get this selection coefficient that allows us
to compare mutations between each other.
Allows us to say, "This one is
giving twice as much advantage to the cancer as this other
one."
And in a particular talk that we have
today in epistasis, that's also important to say, okay,
now that you have one mutation, how does that impact how much
of a driver something is?
Okay.
So that's one of the most important things to get out from today.
The most common current practice with
epistasis is to try to see co-occurrence and
mutual exclusivity. So probably you've seen this kind of
way of presenting data where you put every single tumor that you
have on your data as a column, and then you see
which ones of those have
mutations inside of each one of the genes.
And then you can see, for example, in this case that I took
just colon adenocarcinoma,
and you see that whenever you have KRAS, those patients tend to not
have BRAF. And
that's why you generally say, okay, you have mutual
exclusivity there, and there must be an epistatic effect that is
preventing KRAS from occurring with BRAF.
Or in the case of APC and KRAS,
it's more likely than not that whenever you have APC, you
have KRAS than not having
KRAS. So that could be
probably something that it's hinting at
synergistic epistatic effect.
So that is the standard approach.
And as I said, that could be interpreted as evidence for synergistic or
antagonistic interactions.
But I want to
give this talk more or less trying to consider actually
if it could actually be telling us that, or if there could other
things be going on there. Because co-occurrence
tells you that mutations appear together, but not why they appear together.
It could be because just mutations
occur very often.
And so it cannot separate the mutagenic environment from selection.
So something that is highly mutable in a
particular
cancer, that will co-occur with almost everything.
And then the other thing that already Jaime was pointing out is you don't
have any directionality. You don't know which mutation came first,
and if it is something where A gives you an advantage of
getting B or the other way around. If B gives you an advantage of getting
A.
And the other thing about co-occurrence and mutual exclusivity is
that it's purely pairwise. So you cannot scale that to
consider triplets of genes.
And besides, you cannot formally test whether different
epistatic effects occurred in different kinds
of populations. So I'll be
introducing here a little bit of what Jeff is going to talk about in the
next talk. He's going to be talking about smokers and nonsmokers,
but just want you to keep that in mind.
So generally, we'll start here,
the model. I'll just show you the model in general.
We have what is called a substitution rate.
So you don't have a mutation, and then you observe it in tumors.
So in order to observe it in tumors, then the mutation has to be occurring at
a certain rate. And that rate is going to be
combiningThe mutation rate, so
how often things actually occur in the cell with this
part of fixation, which is the selection.
Okay. And whenever you introduce another gene,
then you can check
if these two rates at which things are occurring,
if they are different from each other.
So if the presence of B changes how
often you get to AB compared to whenever you don't have
B.
But of course, what I want you to remember is that these rates at
which you're observing, they have both the mutation rate and the
fixation. So we have to separate those to be able to actually
be talking actually about epistasis.
So generally it occurs when these things are different, but not necessarily.
Okay, so in general, so if you're
considering just two genes, you're going to have four different ways of
going through here. You can either gain A and then
gain B, or B and then A, and that gives you four substitution rates.
And each rate what is going to capture is how fast that step occurs in the
evolutionary process. And as I said, that includes
mutation and the part of selection.
So in our model, the mathematical model, what we're going to do is just estimate
those four rates jointly from tumor sample counts.
And I'll explain very briefly about how we do that.
First, I want you to consider what would happen if you have more genes in a
network. So if you have three genes, you have plenty
more. You have 12 substitution rates and six different evolutionary
pathways where you can go to
having the three mutations, and this gets exponentially more
complicated as you add more genes.
So
already with four genes it's very complicated, all the different pathways
that you can take. And this grows exponentially, and the bad thing about
this is that whenever something grows exponentially, your data doesn't grow
exponentially. So your data generally grows
linearly, so you wait a couple of months, and then you have instead of 500 samples,
600 samples.
But if you have to estimate,
if you just put another two to the n here, then things get out of hand.
So
that's the bad thing about this. But, yeah, we're
going to eventually get more data to be able to get more
genes at the same time.
Just very briefly, I'll tell you a little bit about our model for those
interested in the actual mathematical model part.
What we do is we try to keep a
model that allows us to identify when you have a different somatic
genotype at a specific time.
And what we do is we assume constant substitution rates from
jumps.
So those arrows that I showed you before, we assume that those are going to be
constant all the time. And what that gives us in mathematics is
something called a continuous Markov chain that you can do
mathematical
formulas and can actually get results from
there. So, important thing here is that we're considering only one
gene can mutate at a time.
So note this effects where you have something that completely
changes at a time, but this can be applied for
SMBs.
And in the math part, what we do is we
compute a recursive formula for
this thing, the probabilities.
And then with that formula, then what we can do is just
get input of standard
tumor genomic data, and the output is going to be those substitution rates.
And we still are not done because, as I said, those substitution rates
have the mutation and the selection, and we have to
remove the mutation in order to get the
selection rate.
So
formally what we have is number of tumor samples in each one of the somatic
genotypes, and we consider all the possible somatic genotypes.
And that allows us to build with the formulas that we get from before, that allows
us to build a likelihood, and then it's just a standard
maximize the likelihood kind of approach, or if you want to get more fancy, you
do Bayesian analysis so you can get posteriors out of this.
No special data are required beyond routine tumor sequencing data.
So TCGA, ARC, Project Genie, anything like that, institutional
cohorts, all of those are usable, and you get back the
substitution rates. And then now what you do is you remove from
the substitution rate, this part that is the mutation rate,
which actually I'm calling the mutation rate, but it's
better defined as a neutral fixation rate
for that gene or variant. So it's something that you
get out of
other tools,
something like BNDS that Jaime was talking about.
We have another tool called SigMutCel.
That is a signature base estimation that uses
also covariates. DNDS also uses covariates to get the best
mutation rate possible. And then when you remove this from the
substitution rates, then you're going to obtain finally the selection, and that's
what you're interested in. So if something is larger than one,
then you have a driver there, a
positive acceleration, but you can also compare them between each other.
So if something is twice as much of a driver compared to another
mutation.
You also see whenever you have something that is
counter-selected, and you have a way of saying
if something is actually neutral, so completely passenger.
So as you can see, co-occurrence
wouldoccur
either because this is very large for both of them,
so that wouldn't be an epistatic effect.
So what's important with epistatic effects is
actually the ones that are driven
only by selection.
Okay, so let's go back to this, the actual data that we have.
So now how do we split that in terms
of the model? So the first thing is to obtain those substitution rates.
So what I'm going to be looking at here is each one of the somatic
genotypes. So these very few patients, one or two or
three, maybe, that have the three mutations at the same time, I'm going to
put those into one category. All of these that have APC and
KRAS but not BRF, I put those in a
different category, and so on and so forth for each one of the different
subtypes.
So that's how it would look like with TCGA COAD data
that I just showed you. So for some of them, you don't
have any of those three mutations.
And most of the time, what you get is a lot of mutations on the first
categories that have BRF, but not KRAS or APC,
and sometimes,
a little bit more on genes that co-occur together, APC and KRAS, you have
plenty here.
And then as you go to the right of these kind of graphs, then you see
less and less
tumors that have
most of the mutations.
So what you do is you feed that into our mathematical model,
and what's going to give you is those arrows.
So the width of the arrows here is going to be the substitution rate.
And you see
at which rate you're going faster from here to here.
So here you're going very fast,
here not so much.
And that is the substitution rate.
And then what you do is now you remove from those substitution rates the
part that is just purely mutation, that is neutral.
The way that we did this in the first paper was we just fit the
neutral mutation rates that we had from different things.
Actually, the first time we just used the NDS.
So the NDS gives you neutral mutation rates.
So this would be the neutral mutation rates.
What we're doing now, we thought more about it, is
that we actually consider that these neutral mutation rates can
change because you have mutations in other genes.
So not only you have this epistatic effect,
well it's not an epistatic effect, but you have this effect of mutations
influence not only the selection, but they can also
influence the mutation as well. So what we do
now is we consider how many mutations you see in
these different somatic genotypes.
So you consider the average tumor mutation burden.
You see here at the beginning, people are not having as many mutations.
So what we do is we use these average tumor mutation burdens to
adjust the jumps of the neutral mutation rates.
So instead of just considering that all the rates never
change, what we see is that whenever you're in these categories
here,
these jumps are going to happen more often
than whenever you were here. So we adjust those neutral mutation rates.
Okay, now and then we take them out of the substitution rates, and this is
actually where you finish, where you have only the selection coefficients.
And then this is where the epistatic effects are actually going to be revealed.
And then you can start asking yourself the questions that you were asking
before. So whenever we were considering, okay, what's
happening that we don't see BRF and KRAS together?
Then you can see that whenever you
jump to KRAS, the selection towards BRF,
it
almost disappears. So
that means that KRAS has a
very strong antagonistic effect against BRF, and
the same is true the other way around, but not so much.
So whenever you jump to BRF,
the KRAS selection, it also
diminishes compared to whenever you didn't have the mutation,
but
it's still there. So most of the
reason why you don't see that often would be because of this path.
Getting KRAS has a
large antagonistic effect against BRF.
And you actually see that APC and KRAS, they don't influence
each other that much. I'm sure that if I
would show you the results with confidence intervals, you'd
actually be able to see that these actually might be significant or
not. But the result is not as striking as the other way.
So this is happening more because APC and KRAS
are both happening very often, that you
see them co-occurring, and not so much because they
actually help each other.
Okay. So
besides that, I want you to see that you can also
start to formalize and actually do statistical
tests
just because you have actual coefficients, and then you can compare, so
you can just
put
null hypothesis of saying, okay, like this jump, is it actually
equal to one? And that's just going to be using
Wilk's theorem and likelihood ratio test with chi-squares that
allow you to compare things. And you can also
have a formal test for saying if there's an epistatic effect
or not. You can compare
just these two arrows, so from normal to A or just B to AB,
if they're different from each other with null hypothesis.
And
in the next talk, Jeff is going to talk more about how actually you can compare
between different populations as well.
So you can split the two populations into smokers and non-smokers and
actually see, is there an epistatic effect?That is different
from smokers and non-smokers.
Okay.
So
just in general, I just
want you to take from this what is the framework, what does it
tell our researchers and clinicians.
You can actually see dominant paths towards oncogenesis.
So you can see out of
these kind of things, where you go more often, and you can
actually compute those with mathematical formulas of which one is the path that
occurs more often.
And that
it's going to be able to
give you some advantage with interventions as well.
You can see where there's antagonistic
epistasis, and just with data, you
don't need to be doing
cell
synthetic lethality with cell lines hypothesis.
You can also see synergistic epistatic effects that
will predict when things will co-occur,
and that could inform combinatory
therapy vulnerability.
Population level tests that Jeff is going to talk more about later.
And it's just rich prognosis in general, and it's genotype
specific selection coefficients.
It's not only two genes, it's also the
ordering and it's also what specific genotype, if there's a
third gene involved.
And yeah, so that's what I want you to all get out of
this, that you don't need to do co-occurrence and mutual exclusivity.
You can just use our model, and that's going to give you
whatever you get from co-occurrence and mutual exclusivity and much
more. And you just need exactly the same kind of
data.
So with that, I would like to conclude.
This is the paper that
we published recently with the first methods.
If you want to get it.
And this is the signature-based mutation rate estimation,
and selection inference that I mentioned about how to
actually get those mutation rates.
So, it's built on Python, and there's plenty of
tutorials there of how to get those.
And any questions, if we don't have time today, you
can email me at
jorgealfaro@ucr.ac.cr.
All right. Thank you very much.
Please come to the microphones with questions.
And also remember, if you don't get your question in now, you should be able to
get it
during the panel discussion.
Hi. Thank you very much. Sherman Mayo.
So I'm wondering how you think about biallelic
changes.
If you have a heterozygous mutation, it could code for an
immunogenic protein, and maybe that
affects it. Or if you have a heterozygous mutation, maybe that
gene is now prone to biallelic loss through its own
intrinsic structure. So I'm just wondering how that
plays into this model. Thank you.
Yes. So far, I don't think we have considered that.
But yeah, it's something that is definitely worth considering.
What we have done,
I guess
maybe ties into that, is whenever we're calculating the
mutation rates, we are considering also gene
expression as the covariates. And gene expression
changes a little bit whenever you have that.
So it is considering that, but only in the part that we're
calculating the mutation rate, not yet on the selection, and
should be something that we should be considering. Thank you.
Maybe I'll just add a gloss that it shouldn't be too difficult to do that.
We just haven't done it.
Yeah.
Like the theory as it works, you could basically call each
allele kind of a gene in that network and
map it through.
Hi. Excellent talk.
My name is Mariana. I'm coming from Yale.
I was just curious if you had implemented this pipeline to look at
treatment status and sort of different treatments that patients get in the context
of maybe resistance, because I feel like the mutations can be different
along the trajectory without treatment compared to once you start-
Right
... adding those pressures.
Yeah. You're completely right. Yeah, most of the time what we do is
actually more try to consider the first stage where treatment has not been
introduced, so we actually filter for those.
But there's work from Jeff's lab that has
considered different stages. So it's more or less what Jeff is
going to talk about right now, where you just split the population and then
consider them as different things, and then you can consider the mutation rates as
different as well. Which is also very important because,
yes, as you're saying, the treatment is going to impact a lot the
mutation rates. So that is very important. Yes.
I'll refer you to a poster by Kira Glasmaker, which is exactly on
that stage specific question.
Thank you.
Over here.
Hi. Great talk. I was wondering if you have any insight on how to incorporate copy
number alterations into this and potentially-
Yes
... if there are any interactions that you think would be important.
Yes. We are working on that, and I think a paper should be published
very soon. Yeah. And
I'm actually working besides that on
in this part of calculating the mutation rate, the Sigmod cell.
The methods are there, well, more or less.
I'm working on actually getting mutation rates out of any possible,
not only copy number variations, but also indels and...
anything like that, because we have signatures from each one of those, and that's
actually what we're using as the baseline for computing the
mutation rates.
Thank you.
And I'll refer you to a poster by Mia Lu, who's actually right next to you
which will be on copy number inference of selection coefficients.
Not exactly epistasis yet, but hopefully soon.
All right.
Oh, okay.
My question is,
I guess I'm not understanding, can't you just sort of
infer the order of mutation acquisition by variant allele
frequency?
If you've got the first mutation is going to be a higher
variant allele frequency, and then the other one's going to be a subclone
typically.
Yes, probably you can.
Again, what we also want to get at is not only the order,
but how that order is important in terms of the selection as well.
So yeah, that's actually what we want.
But as we were saying, yeah, that's something that we should be taking into
account, and it's more or less because
it hasn't been priority yet or maybe we're just starting
with the simpler version. But yeah, you're right.
It's something that we should be considering as well. Thank you.
Thank you.
Okay.
Thanks again.
Thanks again, Jorge and Jaime. And now I will
close this out and then we'll have a panel discussion.
Ah, there's the title. All right, so the title of my talk is, "Tobacco
Smoking and the Somatic Selective Epistasis in
Lung Adenocarcinoma." And I'm going to add a complication
to everything that has been talked about before, which is that in
addition to somatic differences in terms of genetic
changes affecting the selection coefficient for a particular variant, the
microenvironment of that tumor also is going to affect the selection coefficients
that we get. So whenever we talk about
some selection coefficient on KRAS or P53 or APC, that's
really an average selection coefficient, depending on the tumor microenvironment of
every different patient. And in particular, in this talk, I'm only going to
talk about one covariate, which is
smoking, and look at the differences in selection that occur
in lung cancer when it is exposed to smoking and not.
For the first part of the talk, I'll be talking
about these gene by environment interactions and much the same
line of thought that has been talked about
so far.
And then I'm going to talk, I have quite a few slides at the end about the clinical
implications, which may be of interest.
All right, so gene-environment interactions and epistasis shape the
evolutionary trajectories of lung adenocarcinoma.
Tobacco smoke is classically viewed as a mutagen.
We usually think about it as causing mutations, and that's the problem.
But it also alters the lung microenvironment.
If you've ever seen a smoker's lung, it's very different from a normal lung, and
that translates all the way down to the cellular level.
And so it probably changes some of the selection coefficients on genes.
At least that's the hypothesis we were working at when we looked at this project.
So it should shape the selection on mutations.
Disentangling the mutation rates from the selection reveals that the
differences in driver mutation prevalence between smokers and non-smokers
often reflect gene by environment interactions, not just mutagenesis
differences between
smokers and non-smokers. And smoking-dependent epistatic interactions
among driver mutations can play key roles in constraining or enabling
evolutionary trajectories.
So we wanted to look at lung adenocarcinoma because it provides substantial
power for understanding the effect of smoking on oncogenesis.
If you look at the four major lung cancer types, large
cell, squamous cell,
small cell, and adenocarcinoma, we have
the most non-smokers and the largest population in lung adenocarcinoma.
So we thought it would give us the best comparison by environment
within a cancer type. So that's what I'll
talk about today. And just to start with the overall
landscape, again, this is the average selection coefficient across all environments
and
somatic genetic contexts.
This is what we find.
And here we're just looking at the prevalence, so just how often do we
see P53 or KRAS or KEAP1 or STK11 or
SMARCA4 or ATM, RBM10 or EGFR?
And you can see between smokers, so ever and
never smokers, the ever smokers are in teal, and the never smokers are
in this
red color.
There's not
much difference between P53, but there's a big difference between
KRAS.
So KRAS is seen much more in smokers than non-smokers.
Also KEAP1, STK11, and even SMARCA4 to some degree,
are seen much more in smokers than in non-smokers.
But if we go all the way down to EGFR, you see the opposite pattern, where
non-smokers have EGFR mutations at much higher rates
than smokers. So one question is, is this just the product of
mutation rate differences? Because smoking is a major
mutagen, maybe it just mutates KRAS a lot more.
Or is this actually the product of selection?
Is there a difference in the lung microenvironment?
So those are the ones we're going to highlight in the rest of this talk, so keep
track of them.And later I'll talk about some of the clinical
implications of these mutations as well.
So mutation prevalence, what I just showed you, reflects the cellular
mutation rate and selection for survival and proliferation.
So you might have this prevalence.
If you look at the prevalence of P53 and CSMD3, for instance, they're both
reasonably prevalent. But if you then do this
deconvolution we've all talked about today to try to understand how much
mutation is responsible for each one, you see that CSMD3 is mostly
present because it just happens so frequently in cells.
Because it's a
low expressed long gene, you get a lot of mutations in CSMD3.
Whereas P53, on the other hand, has a much lower mutation rate than
CSMD3, and so the strength of selection you would
infer based on this difference in prevalence.
You have very
opposing inferences about what's causing those mutations.
And this has long been known in terms of detecting these genes as
drivers or not, but it's really important for the quantitative estimation as
Dr. Morello was talking about just a moment ago.
So,
let's look at the results. If we look at gene mutation rates by smoker status,
we do
indeed see that
different genes have different rates of mutation in ever smokers on the
Y-axis compared to the rate in never smokers on the X-axis.
Generally, they're significantly elevated in smokers.
Smoking is a mutagen. But different genes actually have different
degrees of elevation due to mutation, which is why we need to
properly deconvolve that mutation for the separate populations of
smokers and non-smokers. We can't assume the same mutation rate, of course, between
these two populations.
And in particular,
there's some remarkable results where ALK and GNAS have much higher mutation
rates in smokers, and that's important to keep track of because if we see elevated
prevalence of ALK and GNAS mutations, that may be just due to
mutation. It may have nothing to do with whether it actually cause
proliferation or survival in cells better.
All right. And the two that I'm going to talk about a lot are EGFR
and KRAS, and you can see that both of these are elevated
in smokers.
This is interesting in particular.
EGFR is elevated
in smokers.
And if you think back to that previous slide, EGFR was
actually less frequent
in smokers.
So I'll let you think for a moment what that means about the relative selection or
mutation rates, and I'll show you the result.
So,
in a moment. And what we're going to do also
to add the complication that this session is about is we're going to look at how
epistasis can further differentiate these adaptive landscapes of ever
smoker and never smoker tumors. So on the left, you
just see this diagram. These individuals are labeled for having P53 in
purple or KRAS mutations in green, and some individuals
have both, some individuals have none, and some individuals have one or the other.
And then we can divide those into the never smokers and the ever smokers,
and the patterns of what is mutated and what is not mutated are different in
these two populations. And then we can construct
these diagrams that
Dr. Alfaro-Morro was just explaining to you,
of interactive... of
sort of like no mutations to one mutation,
to both mutations. And then we can do our analysis that we just
described.
So, if you do this on ever and never smoker, you can see that
ever and never smoker status and prior somatic alterations do affect the
evolutionary trajectory. So up here, on the
left-hand side, these are the fixation rates
or the substitution rates. That's
accounting for both mutation and selection in never smokers and smokers.
And what you can see is that, for instance, KRAS rates in general are
lower in the never smokers. That's not
a big surprise given the prevalence differences. Our method should infer that.
And then we look at the underlying mutation rates.
You can see the mutation rates are definitely higher in smokers.
And then if we look at selection, you see there are differences in selection, in
particular
between KRAS, which is much higher
selected apparently in smokers than in non-smokers.
And then we'll quantify that in just a moment.
So,
what we find is that this pairwise epistasis is common in ever smokers.
So it's a little bit of a complicated diagram, so let me walk you through it.
We're looking at a particular gene, and then we're asking, what is the
mutation rate or the selection for a gene X
mutation? That is this mutation on the left.
What's the selection for this mutation after somatic
mutation of gene Z? So,
after mutation of KRAS, what's the selection for P53,
et cetera? And what we find is, this is a whole lot of mutations here at zero.
So what we find is that for both P53 and KRAS, they
are antagonized by most prior mutations.
In other words, you get some other mutation first, you don't get P53 or KRAS.
So that's why that is in a mechanistic
sense, why P53 and KRAS are
origin genes. They're genes that happen early.
Because if you get those other mutations, we can't say from our analysis
today why it is, but I would speculate that the problem is those other mutations
kill the cells unless you've already got a P53 or KRAS mutation.
And so you don't get that trajectory of those other mutations and then KRAS
or P53. You only get KRAS or P53 first, then these other mutations.
All right. So that's
that kind of example. The opposite example I'll show you for SDK
11, where it's benefited by prior KRAS or KEAP1
mutations. So, you can see here, KRAS and
KEAP1 mutations
increase compared to the SDK 11 without either of them rate
of mutation. So KRAS and KEAP1 are synergistically
increasing the rate of SDK 11 as a
mutation.Now, it can get even more complicated.
So if you look at epistatic interactions, they sometimes differ between
ever smokers and never smokers, the interactions themselves.
So here we have our typical gene-by-gene epistatic
interaction. So this whole plot down here is a plot of
selection for BRAF mutations, and this is how strong that
selection is. Here we have the wild type.
So in a wild type, what's the selection for a BRAF mutation? And this is it.
In a PI3 kinase mutant, here's the selection, and this is it.
The confidence interval there.
On the other hand,
if we take the wild type and mutant,
and look at the selection for
BRAF mutations, you see that we get basically the same
pattern by wild type and mutant,
regardless of whether you are a smoker or a
non-smoker. So essentially, there's a G-by-G interaction.
It's just the genes that matter here. The environment doesn't.
But this second column shows you an example of a gene-by-environment interaction,
G-by-E, where selection for KEAP1 mutations is happening.
And if we look at a smoker, the selection is strongest.
In an EGFR mutant of that smoker, the selection is slightly weaker.
But if you go to the never smokers, the selection is weaker than either of these.
And although we can't tell statistically significantly, but it looks like maybe
a little bit weaker in EGFR mutant even.
And then we get some very odd combinations.
The best way for us to explain the data here is that there's a
G-by-E interaction, but also a G-by-G interaction, and also a G-by-G-by-E
interaction, because we have statistical significance for the
wild type
smoker being different from P53 mutant,
being different from either of the non-smoker selection
intensities. And the wild type
non-smoker
selection for EGFR is different from the selection for
EGFR in the case of a P53
mutant. So every one of these categories, it's different.
And so that requires a lot of different interactions to explain.
Okay, so these higher order interactions are important because they guide
evolutionary trajectories, as was mentioned in the previous talks.
And what we see here is an interesting case where we have a sub-additive
effect on PI3 kinase mutation. So
PI3 kinase mutation are these arrows heading upward,
that are all green here. And the point is that
the
rates are
lower after KRAS compared to from KEAP1.
So we have a pretty complex
relationship among the rates of PI3 kinase mutations, depending
upon the original context. And this is for selection in
smokers in particular.
So I want to come to a bunch of conclusions for you.
I have quite a few text slides here, so hang with me while I talk through them.
The scientific conclusions of what I just talked about are that the adaptive
landscape of lung adenocarcinoma is substantially
different between ever smokers and never smokers.
And I didn't have the slide here,
but you can actually see differences in the amount of synergism and the
amount of antagonism between the two as well.
So certain mutations, just to get granular, KRAS and
KEAP1 and SDK11 are stronger drivers of tumor growth in
ever smoker LUAD. That is, smoking tends to increase the
selection for KRAS, KEAP1 and SDK11.
For others, like EGFR, PI3 kinase, and SMAD4, they're
stronger drivers in never smoker lung adenocarcinoma.
Pairwise and higher order epistatic interactions are prevalent in
LUAD and further differentiate the adaptive landscape of smokers.
So we really need to think about the order of mutations in order to understand how
this trajectory happens. And what we need to follow on with that is that
treatments should consider not only mutations in isolation,
but the entire genetic architecture of the tumor in terms of where is
this patient along this trajectory, and that's how we should think about how
we treat tumors.
Measures of selection contextualized by the surrounding genotype
and environment should inform precision oncology and therapeutic development.
It's important to track these things.
So, second slide of scientific conclusions.
P53 and KRAS were widely antagonized by other driver
mutations, and this is consistent with their early clonal emergence during lung
adenocarcinoma.
And also, it supports their frequently primary role
in tumor initiation.
In terms of preclinical validation, preclinical work that validates what
I just told you from our tumor data analysis.
Our preclinical work is consistent with
our finding that KRAS mutations synergistically enhance selection for
KEAP1 and SDK11 mutations. Prior studies
also show that KEAP1 loss accelerates LUAD progression
in KRAS mutant mouse tumors.
More preclinical validation. KEAP1 loss compensates
for the deleterious effects of KRAS SDK11
co-mutation.
I just want to talk a bit about clinical alignment with trials.
So, it turns out that mutations of KEAP1 and/or SDK11
worsen survival and treatment response in KRAS
mutant lung adenocarcinoma. That's consistent with the epistasis
inference that we get. And also, these mutations
worsen survival and treatment
response in KRAS mutant non-small cell lung cancer in general.
Many papers supporting this result.A little more clinical
alignment, experimental and observational.
Our analyses also identified synergies between EGFR and other drivers,
RBM10 and catenin B1
in nonsmoker LUAD, and RB1 in both nonsmoker and
ever smoker LUAD. These interactions are corroborated by experimental and clinical
studies that show that RBM10 mutations promote
EGFR mutant LUAD and confer resistance to EGFR
TKIs. So that's consistent with our inferences that RBM10 is
synergistic with EGFR mutant LUAD.
Catenin B1 mutations are enriched in advanced EGFR mutant and
nonsmall cell lung cancer and are associated with
metastasis and TKI resistance. And lastly, RB1 mutations
in EGFR mutant LUAD mediate histological transformation to small cell
lung cancer. So,
the synergistic selection of RB1 mutations in the context
of EGFR makes total sense with that as well.
Further clinical alignment. Current non-small cell lung
cancer treatment guidelines for EGFR TKIs do not account for co-occurring
mutations.
However, our findings suggest that concurrent mutations could serve as biomarkers
of treatment response. Antagonistic epistasis between EGFR
and
KRAS or KEAP1 implies that the efficiency of EGFR
TKIs may be reduced in tumors that harbor these
concurrent alterations, and the prediction aligns with
clinical observations. So KRAS mutations decrease survival
in patients with EGFR mutant LUAD patients treated with EGFR
TKIs, and also KEAP1 mutations reduced
EGFR TKI efficiency in EGFR mutant lung cancer.
So this precision medicine
really does tell you a lot about prognosis, and the interactions between these
genes tell you a lot that needs to be kept track of.
It's not just is the gene there or not, it's what
else is there that determines whether it's going to
be effective in that way. A little bit more clinical alignment.
In accordance with the inferred mutually synergistic effect of
mutations of KEAP1 and STK11 in ever smoker LUAD,
co-mutation of KEAP1 and STK11 promotes cell
proliferation
and worsens survival in non-small cell lung cancer
independently of KRAS,
all consistent with the epistatic results that we obtained.
Clinical alignment in terms of trials, a little bit more.
Clinical trials for lung cancer therapies often do not
assess the influence of smoking status.
So many clinical trials for lung cancer
don't look at that as a covariate that they need to account for
and frequently do not even collect the usage history,
perhaps due to a conception that tobacco smoke has a negligible effect on
outcomes.
But this lack of assessment and tracking really must change because these two
diseases are considerably different because of the dramatic physiological
differences that smoking induces on the lung that change the
genetic trajectories that this cancer can follow.
These findings that I've showed you today reveal that tobacco smoke profoundly
reshapes the evolutionary trajectory of lung adenocarcinoma and necessitates
a more systematic incorporation of smoking history into trial
design and treatment decision-making, particularly for targeted
therapies.
And the substantially stronger selection for EGFR mutations in
never smoker LUAD implies that EGFR tyrosine kinase
inhibitors should yield greater clinical benefit in never smokers.
Indeed, a retrospective analysis of patients with EGFR mutant
LUAD found that the objective response rate of patients receiving EGFR
TKIs declined from 73% among never smokers to
46% among individuals with over 10 pack years of smoking history.
So that finding is already validated with
data.
Similar patterns have been reported in additional retrospective studies of
lung adenocarcinoma and across non-small cell lung cancer more
broadly.
And that's the end of my presentation.
I have just four and a half minutes for direct questions to me, and then we'll
move into our panel phase.
Yes.
Thanks.
So
very cool talk. I'm Matt Leventhal from Boston.
Hi.
And
what is the kind of landscape of folks having looked at
PARP inhibition in smokers with lung cancer?
Because the implication here
is that you get rid of your cell cycle and DNA damage
checkpoints, and that they're more effective in driving evolution in the
ever smokers. So I'm curious if people have looked then, if synthetic
lethality with PARP inhibition is especially effective in ever
smokers.
That sounds like a fabulous question.
I have no answer for you because I've never looked into PARP inhibition in smokers.
But in principle, we can look at different populations with PARP and with
bioPARP. There's tons of questions we could ask along those lines.
And also look at different DNA damage
phenotypes or genotypes as well, and that could also illuminate
these kinds of questions. There's a ton of ways you can sort of look at this data,
and I think a ton of ways where looking at this data can be extremely informative
about which clinical courses to try and take.
If you have a hypothesis and you haven't used the tumor data to ask the
question beforehand, why haven't you?
Because you can, and it probably will tell you the answer long before
you can get a clinical trial done, and it will tell you how strong that result is
going to be. So let's use this data to tell us which ways we
need to go in these studies.
Thank you.
Thank you. Great talk.
I had a question on whether or not you've tried to integrate proteomics
data into some of these states. Just observing
from one state to another, if you can segregate your data well enough, can
you see the difference in proteomic changes when you acquire that second
mutation in different groups? Have you tried that?
Have you looked into adding one more omics layer based off of
your groups in epistasis?
I'm delighted to hear your enthusiasm. No, we haven't.
This is the only population difference study that we've done with this technique so
far. So we have not done that, but it totally makes sense.
If there's any particular marker you think really distinguishes different
populations that are experiencing a different cancer evolutionary trajectory,
I think using that to separate those two populations and examine how that
trajectory differs and looking at the implications for clinical
outcomes is a really bright idea.
Great. Thank you.
Hi. Hello.
I need to
confirm if I am understanding or not.
So looks like the
smokers have a completely different microenvironment because of the
chronic inflammation. Are you saying that that
microenvironment needs different
mutations
compared to non-smokers? A different mutation and a different
trajectory-
Yeah
... because the environment is selecting differently? Is that what you're saying?
Absolutely, 100%. And I just want to apologize because one of my slides
apparently didn't come through. I don't think you've noticed, but there was a blank
slide in the middle there, and it was one of the coolest slides on here, which
is the comparison between smokers and non-smokers in the total effect size of
these mutations. The other slides sort of got the message across, but
they show you that the ultimate result,
in comparing smokers and non-smokers for KRAS, is to
diminish the effect of the mutation.
But essentially, EGFR is just not selected at all in smokers.
So if you think about that, that's very interesting because smoking is actually
prophylactic for EGFR-driven lung cancer.
That's amazing.
However, of course, you don't want to smoke because it's
mutagenic and it also increases the structure selection for KRAS.
So
if you want to choose a trajectory,
your trajectory is a lot better in the never smoker category.
All right. Thank you, Jeff, for putting together such a wonderful session.
My name's Hunter Shane from UCSF.
And I think my question honestly could go to any of the speakers if when you get up
there you want to anyway.
Can you hold on for one second then? Because we have just 12 seconds left.
Why don't we invite the other speakers up-
Yeah, perfect
... and we'll start our panel session with your question.
So I'll start talking while you get seated.
You all showed this wonderful data where you mathematically
inferred the various routes to cancer.
And
in all the examples you showed, it looks pretty compelling.
There are growing databases of somatic mutations in normal
tissues. I was thinking, Jeff, during your talk, there's a prominent study from
Yoshida et al. that looked at clonal expansions of lung
epithelial cells. And so I'm curious, for instance,
do you see some of the same mutations that you predict are
under stronger selection in a smoking environment, in the normal
epithelia of lung tissue? And the same question could apply to
colon or any of these contexts. Have you guys looked at all these normal
sequencing databases to confirm your mathematical predictions?
Yeah. I'll start with that answer, which is that,
yes, we do see many of the same mutations.
So,
I'm not sure if it's the same talk. There was a lot of authors on some of those
normal studies papers, but a talk by James DeGregori at the last
ASDR meetings, talked about the
sequencing with very high depth, very high accuracy, sequencing normal
cells, which is much harder than with tumor cells because tumor cells sort
of all have a common ancestor and are homogeneous in some ways in their
genetics. Normal cells are from a lot of different stem cell
lineages, so you have to sequence with much more precision and at much
more granular level to get the normal data you're referring to.
And when you do those studies, you see KRAS,
P53. You see basically all of the cancer genes that we talked about
mutated at some frequency. What you probably don't see is the
further trajectory, like multiple mutations that are eventually leading to the
cancer. I think there was a further question to your-- There's more
to your question, and I have missed it.
Yeah, no, it's just more in general,
are your mathematical inferences validated?
If you--
Like in the-
Oh
... talk.
You don't see a lot of APC-only driven colon cancers.
Yeah.
But you would expect to see APC mutant colonic epithelial cells.
And of course, in that specific example, an APC mutation would result in a
polyp probably. But are some of these inferred
intermediates, are they supported in some of the normal sequencing studies that are
coming out?
Yeah. So I just want to comment that you can ask that question with the normal
sequencing studies, and it's wonderful because you're directly asking the question
of data.
You can actually even ask that question of some bulk tumor
data for normal and
tumor data. And there's a
normal neoplasia, so to speak, that is clonal growths that are not
cancerous.
And you can look at those and compare them to tumors.
And when you do that, you see that some differences, in fact,
are...
Some things are selected in that early phase and are not selected
or even possibly negatively selected in the later phase.
The great example of this that has been talked about a lot is Notch 1 in
esophageal cancer. Inigo Martin-Carina had a paper where that was
basically speculated in humans. Then just recently a paper came out...
showing in a mouse model that that's true, and then we have a paper that's
making its way through that shows that in humans it's true based on the human tumor
sequence data. And you can see that, that's a
poster by
Kira Glasmacher, who's here, if you're interested in that.
Hi. Thanks for the excellent talks. I'm Charlotte Grieco.
I'm a PhD student and clinician with Charlie Swanton.
And I wondered about whether you'd thought about the impact of germline alterations
on the host selective environment of these tumors, and is that something that you
can model at all? Because it's often overlooked in these never smoking lung
cancers.
I have something to say, but I want to give you a chance to first.
I didn't hear well.
Well, the question was, have you thought about
starting with thinking about germline as well as somatic mutations in their
interactions?
Yes. So we
actually started looking at that, then we had to stop due to complications in
with staff and funding. But yes, that's an ongoing project.
Unfortunately, I can't give you any preliminary results yet.
We've also looked at that some. In principle, there's not all that
much difference in how we look at it compared to the somatic evolution.
The problem is that, you may remember the point that, as
the more mutations you look at, the more pathways are there, and it sort of
blows up and becomes problematic.
Similarly, or it's not exactly the same problem, but another problem is
that with germline mutations, most of the ones that have a significant phenotypic
effect or cancer effect are at low frequency.
So in most tumor sample data that you look at, you get very few
of the original mutation, germline mutation, and with very few of the original
germline mutation, there's very little you can infer about epistasis, because
if you have four or five tumors,
you can't really figure out whether it's an abnormal frequency of various somatic
mutation combinations. So there's a nexus here, which is really
problematic, but as we get these really, really big data sets, I think we're
going to be able to start addressing that question much better than we have in the
past. Unfortunately, NIH put out this big germline
somatic effort, they put a bunch of funding into it
before we had data sets that were big enough to answer the question.
So we got a lot of...
Everyone did a good job for what they were doing, but we really didn't have the
data to answer the question when they put a push out on that.
So we need another push on it probably in the next two or three years.
We can all pray that happens.
Cool. Wow. We'll watch this space, I guess.
Yeah.
Thanks.
Hi. Christine Chaffa from Garvan Institute, Australia.
I know you haven't necessarily done a lot of the RNA sequencing
yet, but thinking about where these convergence lies,
so when you have a different... When
Jaime started to talk about modules, I do wonder,
antagonistic or synergistic, I wonder if we bring that up to
the signaling level, whether you start to think about
different combinations of mutations that are converging at
a signaling level on the same pathway.
So, we can sequence and get different events or
different types of mutations in particular patients, but I wonder
whether completely different mutational trajectories might end
up at a signaling level converging, on the same signaling
process, and so we can start to think about commonalities that way.
Yeah. So
what I showed about the correspondence between
network modules and consensus molecular subtypes,
actually, many of these consensus molecular subtypes are based on transcription
levels. So we did not actually take the transcription data
and compare it with the module. We just took the
available classification at the TCEA, about
some people who have classified the subtypes, and then we looked if there was
correspondence. Because we could actually now, with more data, do it
on our own, just basically go to the transcriptional profiles and see if
there is closer similarity between members of the same
module.
I would expect that that's going to be the case, because we see
correspondence using classifications that other people have done.
We haven't tried yet, but I would expect that there is, yes, based on what
we saw with these consensus molecular subtypes that are based on transcriptomics
done by other people.
And I didn't talk about it in my talk, but we did look at transcriptomics between
the smokers and non-smokers,
and there's a really strong correspondence between EMT,
and where EMT gets induced and doesn't, that aligns up very much
with the phenomenological differences in terms of the
selection
for or against EGFR in particular.
So you can do that on the environmental side, but I bet you could do it just as
easily on the genetic side, although we haven't done that.
Yeah. Cool. Thanks.
Over here.
Thank you for the session. It's very meaningful.
This is Fulvio D'Angelo from University of Miami, and I really like your
model. I think it's great. I just was wondering if you
could implement multiple level of complexity in this
model. For example, the type-
Could you just move a little closer to the microphone? I can't hear you.
Yes. Sorry. If you could implement additional
level of complexity in this model, for example, the type of mutation.
If it's a missense, it's a frame shift, it's an in-frame mutation.
If it's a passenger mutation or it's a driver mutation.
Yeah.
Because, for example, if you have a passenger mutation by
itself, is not pathogenic, but if co-occur
with the other passenger or driver mutation can have an
effect. So I was wondering if we could add this
additional level of complexity in the model.
I was also wondering about the subclonality of the mutation.
So if a mutation is subclonal or
is truncal in the tumor, if this can affect
the epistasis of the tumor.
Yes, we are
doing progress on that area.
The key point is the first part I show you where you actually
get the substitution rates, that's no problem. You can put whatever you want.
You can put
missense mutations, you can put indels, you can put copy numbers.
That's not going to be a problem. What is more challenging is actually
getting a baseline mutation rate for those other types of
mutations, because with the NDS,
what Jaime's been using, what you need is synonymous mutations.
What we're actually using with the new method is
considering the fact that we have so many passenger genes,
passenger mutations. So we use the fact that we have so
many more of those, and we actually use those to infer
the baseline mutation rates.
So we are making progress on that into incorporating
other types of mutations.
And I think we should get there soon enough.
And then to your second question, that was about
clonality.
Yeah, it could be a little bit challenging just because of the type of data that we
have. Most of the time we only know that there's a mutation and not so
much how much of it there is.
If we could have... Oh, actually, we have looked into that,
but the other way around, where we
have some tools. Do you remember who published that tool that we were
using to try to see if a mutation happened earlier than another one?
Yeah. There are tools that probably many of you have heard of.
There's a...
Sorry, his first name is Peter. Peter Van Loo has done some work on this, along
with many other collaborators with him.
And we have done some integration.
That was actually related to a question that was asked earlier also.
Some integration of that, because obviously it's relevant to which the order of
these things. And so you can basically incorporate that into the
kind of analysis we're due to add a little bit of informational
strength to the inference. And actually, it is very useful
because
our method has a lot of informational strengths in some areas, and it's a little
bit weaker in others. And it's very complementary, that data, to what we
do. The one thing that maybe you should be aware about that
data is, though, that there's a lot less of it than it looks like when you look at
those papers, because not that the... The papers are completely right.
There's nothing wrong with what they're saying.
But in terms of actually informing some trajectory like this, there's usually
maybe four or five tumors where you actually can say one is before the other.
And so the amount of that data is not that big.
Nonetheless, since it's so complementary, I think it's worthwhile for us to
integrate it. We are working toward that.
We basically have done it, but we just haven't gotten that work
spun out into papers yet.
Thank you.
Great section. And I have a question about have you taken into
consideration of other demographic factors in
your model, for example, like patients' age, sex, and how long they
smoke?
Yeah. I'll refer you to Yihong Lu, who's two people to the right of you right
now. She'll wave at you. She's got a poster on age and selection.
And we have
basically a mathematical model, which Jorge was actually helpful with
as well,
that allows us to look on a continuous scale at age and how that affects
selection across the age of the patient.
And there are some dramatic differences in some genes, and in other genes, there's
no difference whatsoever. So really interesting results that you can see on a
poster by Yihong Lu.
Do we-
Okay, I have actually two quick questions, which maybe other people can listen to
what they want. Jaime, I just wanted you to clarify.
I think I know the answer, but when you're
looking at the modules, can you just clarify what defines
those modules? As in, like all of the things on one side versus all on the other
things on the other side of these gaps?
Yeah. So we define a module as a set of genes that are connected
by a synergistic epistasis
with each other, and then they have negative interactions with the rest.
Okay.
Now, the definition is not just
hard boundary. We actually use a stochastic, sorry, a statistic framework.
So we calculate the probability to have a positive interaction and the probability
to have a negative interaction, and these are more statistically likely
to... So basically, a module is a set of genes that are connected by positive
interactions more likely than you would expect by chance.
Okay. And the follow-up of that is you mentioned that this has effect on
survival outcomes.
Mm-hmm.
How does that relate to the set of genes in a module or the set of genes in another
module? You mean that if the genes in one module are
mutated, that has one survival outcome, and the genes in the other, the other?
Is that what you mean by that?
Yes, that's it.
Okay, great. That wasn't-
Well, we find this, that if you look at an individual tumor,
mutations tend to be... You can clearly assign that tumor to one of the
modules of the network. You don't see distributed mutation in different modules.
They tend to come, most of them, from the same module.
And that way, you can assign a tumor or a patient to a given module of the network,
and then for that, you calculate.
So if you look at, say, the KM plot, the Kaplan-Meier plot
afterwards-
Mm-hmm
... those two modules will have differing-
Yes
... survival. Okay, very interesting.
So
I have one other question,
which is just, could you talk a little bit about how you extended
from the pairwise framework, which I think is how your method mostly
works-
Yes
... to those larger networks, right?
So the math you showed was the difference between two
interactors.
The networks are actually pairwise networks.
If you see, there are links connecting two genes.
In
theory, extending that to higher the interactions is
theoretically is trivial. It's just instead of stratifying based on presence and
absence of one gene, you have two genes, and you have both are present, both are
absent, one class, one or the other. You have four groups.
You stratify based on those four groups, and you calculate everything again.
The problem is that now you need to-
Split your data set in four groups.
Fewer data, inferring the model becomes a problem.
Yeah.
Exactly.
Same problem we encounter. Yep. Oh, I see a question. Please.
Yeah. Wonderful session, Sherman.
Mayo, thank you. I'm wondering if you have done any work
to micro-dissect
things like precursors and understand
which are progressing and which are not.
So I study breast cancer. You see a lot of DCIS,
then you see invasive breast cancer probably arising from one of the
ducts, whether we really demonstrate it spatially or not,
proximity.
Could we understand where the blocks are in progression
and facilitators of progression by doing some of that work?
And how much have you done to look at that? Thanks.
So integrating that with this epistatic network stuff we've done,
we haven't exactly done, because I don't have a good reason
for why. I wish I had
1,000 people to work on the work we're doing.
But
I think it's a really interesting question.
I will comment that, as I mentioned a little bit earlier, we have done
stuff on the stage-specific progression from
these neoplastic DCIS, et cetera, to later stages.
And we have a model that allows us to ask,
what is the selection coefficient in the neoplasia and how does it differ from the
selection coefficient to a primary tumor?
And as I mentioned to a previous question, we do see big differences between
those. So sometimes the neoplasia is very strongly selected for and actually
is kind of protective of later. A good example of that is KLF4
in pancreatic cancer,
and NOTCH1 in esophageal cancer, both of which we've worked on in the lab.
We have papers in the works showing that.
It just comes to mind because when you study cancer, you don't see the one
minus N.
Yeah.
The not cancer and what didn't progress.
That's right.
Why this is very interesting. Thank you.
Very good.
Yeah. And I wouldn't be surprised if the epistatic landscape
changes during tumor evolution.
I was recently... I don't think it's published.
I know that Franz Supek, with one of his students, has been studying that, how
epistatis changes over in early cancer and late cancer, and they found some
interesting differences.
I know that because it was a PhD defense of one of his students,
but I don't think they published it yet.
Okay.
So looks like we're out of questions, and we're pretty much out of time.
So thank you very much for attending this session, and
listening to all of the outstanding research here.
And please have an excellent rest of your ACR meetings.